all right all year
my name is pete but i'm called uh skid
row
uh repeat because uh
when we have an encounter you want to do
it again
uh if you're on the right side and what
i mean by the right side is
uh if you're not bullying somebody or
you know putting somebody down uh
because they're less fortunate than you
are then you know
i can sit at the right side because i'm
a uh
canadofield a canine of phil is a lover
of the underdog
i like the person who has the least
chance of winning because that's how you
know
i went through life like that having the
least chance but you know
i started winning somewhere along that
line anyway um
before i went into before i went into
the navy
um i had got my
70 buick skylark when i was 16. got a 67
chevy low rider
hydraulics the whole works things would
go wrong with the car
i couldn't afford to pay a mechanic to
do things not at this time and sometimes
i didn't want to because i liked the
money in my pocket so i would go out now
with
steal cars i got good at it i got real
good at it i got so good at to where
most of the time i would sit there and i
would time myself uh
sometimes i'd knock on your door wave at
you and walk to your car
get in before you go outside i was gone
as long as it took me at that time
was like 18 seconds and i've considered
that slow i'd be in the car and i'm gone
by the time you run out in your draws
with your gun i didn't care what it was
it was like a adrenaline testimony like
a
move to manhood i got better at it i
also got better at the mechanics
i couldn't afford to pay mechanics i had
to do it myself and when i look at cars
it's like i'm looking at a puzzle or
take it apart and i
remember how it goes back together as i
take it apart when i was younger
seven eight years i should take the tv
apart i couldn't always get it back
together
but i knew how that part was supposed to
go uh my mom got kind of mad at me for
taking the
electronics apart in the house but uh
sometimes i put it back together before
she found out
so uh there's this
particular time to where my brother had
a lot a lot of money and i had called
him up because uh
i was at the low end of the scale and i
told him hey
i need some money man i'm gonna go out
and i'm gonna do something
so he said look just meet me at mom's
house so um
i met my mom's house a couple hours
later he showed up
told me to get in the car and i thought
he was just gonna hand me some money got
in the car and he drove we drove for
like
two hours out to lancaster uh hour and a
half whatever it takes and when we got
to lancaster when this house and the
first time i ever seen his house
i had never knew that this dude had
moved up
to that level his house would you
imagine it was so beautiful i mean i was
amazed
large four bedroom pool in the back
marble i mean i was looking at the stuff
and i knew what it cost because i
went into fred federated store
stereo store and they had the macintosh
system and the cheapest part of the
macintosh was the tune of 4
999 but he had this whole system anyway
uh he told me just relax we're gonna you
know go get some money right
so uh day went by another day went by
you know he
got me brand new clothes and feed me and
i'm getting kind of tired when are you
gonna give me the money so i can go do
my own thing
so he said okay look we will make the
move tomorrow right
so anyway that evening he came with a
brand new honda accord with dillard's
license plate on it he went and
purchased it
uh he took me downtown
l.a where i'm about now and we went to
the japanese all the chinese are
we went to the asian section and he
brought
a ninja suit he brought you know the
whole hookup
tripping off of it and wondering what he
gonna do so uh
he gave me a that night he gave me he
said his 3 8 is jammed
so i took it apart i mean at this time i
was good with weapons i took it apart
uh oiled it cleaned it we went out in
the desert and fired it
cleaned it again put it back together
that morning we got in the car and we
took off
we drove for like 18 hours 19 hours 20
hours
to somewhere around oklahoma
and uh we pulled up in a certain area
and he said uh that's him right there
so i looked like i see you talking about
he said the the green cadillac
such a green cadillac seen a dude and he
gets out he go to a bar and grill pool
hall
he opens it up he goes in he said yeah
he owned that building that's this whole
hookup right there
he said look i gave this dude a small
fortune and he owed me and he never paid
me
he keep telling me he's going to pay me
but he's not giving it to me [ __ ] that
he said we're going to take him down i'm
like all right i'm good with that so he
said uh
let me show you something else we went
to another part of town
and this is physically the first time i
ever seen police
in somebody's pocket what i mean by that
is the dudes were serving dope
police sitting there and they're not
doing nothing i was amazed that they
didn't jump out and bust them matter of
fact the dude opened up his sack on a
police car
took some work out gave it to somebody
got the money and went back talking to
the police i was like wow
that's amazing he said yeah he got the
whole force like that in his pocket
right
so he said uh let me show you where his
sister lived we went to his sister's
place
and he said he keeps at least two birds
in her kitchen under the sink a bird is
a kilo a brick
a thousand grams he said keep at least
two of them a thousand grams at this
time was 25 000
you'd make a hundred thousand dollars
off of it you'd literally make a hundred
thousand dollars
off a kilo so anyway said she keep two
of them
he keep two of them in her kitchen
untaped under the sink
he said he also keep one or two in his
house
under the sink but it's outside in the
garage right so we went
and we drove to another section we
pulled up he said okay that's his house
right there
he said this is what you're gonna know
we pulled off he said i think he lived
by itself but you gotta check it out
so we pulled off two or three miles he
pulled over
he gave when you see gave me the ninja
suit he gave me the 380.
he gave me 500 he said i'll see you when
you get home
he got the car and he stopped walking
away and i just looked at him while he
walked off
uh after he got to the corner i knew he
wasn't joking he turned the corner and
disappeared
so i'm looking around thinking this
[ __ ] thing i'm gonna do okay
that's how you want you want me to do it
on my own all right fantastic i'll put
it down
so got in the driver's seat drove around
now i remember
the section where the pool hall was so i
went back over to that section
and i watched the dude's serving they
would go after under
after they served to their sack they'd
go over to his bar and grill they come
back out and they start serving again
so i knew that was his work he had four
guys so
that night when they left the bar and
grill they served out of their home
so i went to the house and i didn't know
him so i kind of waited down the street
to somebody came by say hey you finna go
out and get something they say yeah i
said what's dude name and they would
tell me his name
i said look i want to go with you i want
to get something like a hundred dollars
all right come on
so i would walk with him i would go in i
would make a purchase and let the dude
see me a couple of times
then i went on my own i let the dude
know that i was gonna buy something
larger
i let them know that hey my name is
chicago uh
we're trying to do something big if you
can handle the weight i'ma go ahead and
start purchasing bird for you
these dudes wanted to excel they wanted
to grow up all of them did
so i went back to him i started short
stopping the people
the people had to walk like two or three
miles to get to a spot so i went
down the road and parked and started
serving them down the road and i go down
and buy some from them
so i built up my clientele through them
for about nine days
every night i knew what time this dude
closed up so i would go sit outside the
bar when he'd drive home i'd follow him
he'd go in the store he'd get a pack of
bents in the head just get 240 ounces of
english
and he'd go home and i'll follow him
home the second time i fought him home i
jumped the gate and i took the trash
i took his trash because the trash would
tell you who an individual is how many
people are there who lives there and so
forth and so on
so i took the trash and i went through
it i know you live by itself now
i know there's no woman no children
because there's no trash for women and
children
there's no lipstick on the cigarettes or
anything else so i know pretty much
when he leaves for work the house is
empty so after about nine days
i make a decision i'm going to go and
get this dude this is the night i'm
gonna get him
because he's a creature of having he was
doing the same thing the same way every
time
so the ninth day i went to go and get
him but
i decided i'm gonna go in the house i'm
gonna find the money
so he had a stucco-styled house so i
took a screwdriver and
dug the stucco away from the bars pulled
the bars out climbed in and
searched the house i set this house for
about an hour hour and a half
and i found a sack of money but it was
one dollar bills it was like four
thousand one dollar bills off in the
closet
so i took it i threw it back in that
wasn't what i was there for i knew he'd
keep anywhere
from a quarter to a whole meal ticket
inside his house from 250
000 to a million dollars inside his
house because he never made deposits in
the bank
so i decided i had to take this the hard
way i couldn't find the money
so i had to wait for him to come home so
i called my brother and i told him hey
look uh i'm finna make this jump and
take him down if i got to he said look
man
this dude is a killer if you slip he
gonna get you so if somebody got to go
it might as well be him instead of you
i'm sorry i got it covered
i waited for the guy to come home he
eventually came home and uh
when he came through i had the ski mask
on i rushed him i rushed him like i was
the police i handcuffed him
hit him in the head turned him over and
told him hey look you got one chance to
live through this
tell me where the money is i'ma blow
your [ __ ] brains out
he told me it was in the mattress in the
bedroom i had felt the mattress but i
didn't feel the money
so i went back cut the mattress and
there was
it was 186 thousand dollars 186 stacks
of thousand dollar bills each stack was
a thousand dollars i put them all in a
bag
left the house but before i left the
house i went back in
and i got the two kilos from under the
sink so i got 186
000 and two kilos when i leave the house
jumping on the cord i hit the highway
i'm doing about 110 because i'm happy i
got this in 110 miles an hour on the
freeway with
two birds sitting out and 186 thousand
dollars on the driver's seat
when i get back home i don't run into my
brother for about a damn trying to catch
up with him i don't run into him
so at this time i go and i do another
move with 186 thousand dollars cash and
two birds i go and do something else i
add to it
i get another half a bird and sixty four
thousand dollars so what i started doing
was i found it was easier
to start robbing the people who sell the
dope than it was to rob
i mean it's not like they was going to
go to call the police and say they got
robbed
anyway uh there was one thing that
kind of kind of went down bad not that i
had to hurt somebody that somebody hurt
me but uh
it went south from the border
turned out that there was a female
in the house when i thought it was a
dude and
she kind of surprised me she surprised
me by walking
in when i thought the house was supposed
to be empty and
i didn't put a hole in her per se
but uh i almost did
close enough to it to where she
bagged up and fell off the second store
window second story window
and um when i looked out she was tangled
up in the bushes downstairs
and she didn't die but she was injured
you know real bad and i made a decision
from that time that uh
that was the end of that i wouldn't uh
be doing what they call now home
invasions
i wasn't doing a home invasion on people
who just
the regular you know citizen i was doing
a home invasion on the ones who
had the money and i knew they had the
money and i would go in most of them
would all
actually all of them was dope dealers so
i would go in and i would liberate them
um eventually
i did uh plug somebody but i'm not going
to really
go into that because there's no statute
of limitations on a variety of things
and
that's not one of the ones i'm going to
go into but um
i wish i wouldn't have i wish i didn't i
never got penned for it and probably
never will because uh
three people can keep a secret if two of
my dead
that would be the only way so i did
everything by myself i didn't take
nobody with me if i did i probably would
have
got rid of them too unless it was a
immediate family member
but i'm not uh particularly proud of a
lot of things
that i did and this was 15 16 years old
when i really didn't have to do it 17
i didn't have to do it but i did it
anyway
i did it because it was more of an
exhilaration there was something to
break the norm
something to test my limited abilities
when i didn't
think i was mortal i thought i was
immortal
but i found out when i did
go into the military and got scrambled
and got hurt it did hurt that i was
mortal that pain
was nothing compared to what happened to
me about three weeks ago
i was sitting in front of a car in a
lounge chair and i had my feet out about
12 inches
and a h2 hummer
came down the street and actually ran
over my foot and i'm only 12 inches out
from the car
my foot is 12 inches out he ran over my
right foot
and i heard a boom first and i thought
he had ran over in my
shin but it was only my foot and when he
ran over my foot i couldn't believe
it i didn't feel the pain immediately
until i stood up and realized what had
happened
and i looked down and i could see the
print the hummer tie did not be tired i
can see it in my shoe
and i knew that same print was in my
foot i knew my foot was shaped like that
like a cartoon
and i jumped up and my girlfriend had
said uh
did i call hit the chair i heard a boom
i said that was my [ __ ] foot
i've never felt pain so i like that
i fell down and i took my shoe off and i
looked at my foot and it was like an
accordion man
and i pulled the other shoe off just for
comparison i looked at him
and the right one is different from the
left one
he ran over my foot literally broke my
right foot in two of my toes and he kept
going
police ambulance everybody came i cussed
i cussed
everybody out you know i fear god but i
was cussing them out too for letting it
happen
he ran off my foot he broke it and i've
never felt i mean i used to walk in the
street blindly i should just ride with
reckless abandon
now when i walk in the street i stay on
the sidewalk and when i cross i look
behind me because
that [ __ ] hurt it and it still hurts now
and it's been about three weeks
i couldn't let them put a cast on me
because they put a cast on me i would
have literally starved to death
who went got my meals who would have
hustled for me i'd have been in trouble
so i kind of braved through it the pain
and everything else and
limped where i needed to go and them to
do what i had to do and i
did a few things but uh
when you live by the sword you die by
the sword you know it comes hard
and uh easy come easy go
and i appreciate the opportunity to uh
be able to devolve something some things
are
interesting other things are casual but
here all you have to do is sit back and
look down the street
and you'll see a movie unfold
something's going to happen
skid row downtown los angeles this is
where we're at
and i can appreciate being here because
once you what's the sign say i
lived through the earthquake i conquered
this
once you live through skid row you've
lived man
you can live just about anywhere now if
you know the language
but this is skid row south central los
angeles
and i appreciate the time i appreciate
your attention
and i appreciate our producer for making
this possible for all of us to have a
voice
there's a racial issue that's going on
and it's a
not a white and black thing it's uh
i would say mexican but that's kind of
offensive i'd say latino but then that
includes everybody
but it's generally the what the group
who considered itself southsiders
you know from southern california and
the blacks they got this
stupid-ass war going on and it evolved
from the prison i thought it was limited
to the prisons
you know i don't dislike people
racist i dislike a person if you dislike
me i dislike you
there's this stupid-ass war going on in
prison
over something that's not yours okay
these are workout bars that's your
toilet this is our benches and
it's nobody's but it's to cause the
separation
and now they're doing it
30s 40s on the west side they're doing
this
same stupid ass things mexicans or
latinos or whatever you want to refer to
yourself as
are jumping on black people
indiscriminately men women and children
and black people are jumping on mexicans
in discriminating men women and children
one thing i know for sure being a black
man
we do not raise our children to hate we
choose we raise them to defend
themselves to stand up for themselves
but we don't raise them hey you hate
because they're mexican you hate them
because they're asian
no we don't do it the other races do it
especially the south side mexicans
they're raising their children
just to hate us because of color not
because they know us
not because they had an incident with us
just because
they hate so they're passing it on
and it took me about 20 years in prison
to realize this
but they're raising their children that
way and i knew was true when i started
hearing about
racial riots in junior high school
it had to be done at an early age for me
to have racial separate racial
segregation
in the schools because when i went to
school we weren't separated we were
whole
it was a whole unit football team
basketball team the whole school
now is divided just like the prisons and
everything else
so united we stand divided we fall
and it's real it's taking place and i
was surprised to hear about it
a couple of weeks ago because i didn't
know it was taking place too it was
brought to me
and i don't have the racial segregation
i don't have the racial discrimination
in my heart and my soul
because i accept everybody i might not
like the individual
but i don't base that on the race
there's only one race that's a human
race
and that's what i have to say excellent
thank you repeat
fantastic man appreciate being here
thank you
you're welcome so the story you talk
about robbing the dealers
did you finish that story not about the
who
who got shot but what happened with all
the money that you got uh [ __ ] you come
as you go
what do you say i thought it was i
thought i was buying everything i
brought brand new motorcycles i brought
a boat my boat my first boat was uh 58
thousand dollars my second was 126
i mean i spent the money i spent it
because i thought i could always do this
i thought it was so easy to do it again
i
maybe pulled it off seven times
and the lowest denomination i got was
like sixty four thousand dollars but
that was the easiest way for me to make
money it was easier than working a job
all i had to do was sit on the street
and listen
and find out who was where and where
they lived and watch them for a while
and they were creature happy they'd do
the same thing and when i can see their
method of operation
i figured out a way in i figured out how
to do it i figured well i was going to
get in where i fit in
and i was able to do it because all i
did was start it out and you spent it
all
yeah and it worked
you know that was the surprising part it
didn't work
exactly the way it's like just like a
military the military the
navy air force have a perfect plan until
the first shot is fired
and then everything's a cluster [ __ ] it
all goes to hell after the first bullet
is fired
it never goes that way always goes a
different way
but i tried to plan for x factors and
by god's will i'm still here
you look great too thank you very much
man so to you mark it's appreciated
thank you
you